Her low freak bitches.
The only one who's getting get
a rematch on the card is Yolana.
She deserves it after,
after defendant,
how that many times you hit murked
in that first round. I think she's,
that qualifies for an immediate rematch.
Well,
I think that's where the
big money is for sure.
I mean people are going to want to see
that. That's a big fight because when,
when you want to walk down to the
pop from the audience was immense.
She's finally become like this star that
they've been putting all this promotion,
the door, she's winning fights. She was
kind of thriving in it a little most.
A little too much. Which is one of
the reasons can should loss. Yeah.
The little bit of the Rhonda Syndrome,
they're little bit why don't
know if it's that, but you know,
she was definitely doing a lot of
press and he learns a lot of fucking
tremendous amount of pressure.
But I'll tell you what, dude,
when she was talking to the camera and
she was talking to rose and she's like,
the Boogie woman coming for you,
the book you woman come in for you.
I kept fucking, we scared. I was legit.
The greatest like Promo of all
time. I was like, Boogie woman.
What the fuck did you see her at looking
at rose in her eyes like staring into
your soul and she's talking about kinds
of crazy shit. I'm going to fuck you up.
I'm going to hurt you.
And rose is saying the Lord's prayer.
It's some demonic shit. I was like, why?
I asked rose there what what he's saying?
She's like, I was saying the Lord's
prayer and she didn't even look at you.
Anybody. She wouldn't look okay. I was
like, all right. I'm like, wow, this is
easy to say. In retrospect. I knew that
something special was going to happen.
Hell No. I thought real. I was
like, Rosen. He see a psychiatrist.
That's why when I saw that way and I'm
like, we need to get rose some help,
pace up forever. I'm like, you know
what? We need some professional help.
But after the fact, knowing the
result that rose won by knockout,
it makes it even all the more profound.
Now you're gonna see motherfuckers just
reciting the lawyers you want to talk
about. I hope the UFC
realizes, and I think they do.
That's a fucking star. That's what
those real talk. Hell yeah. Boy.
Amino real stars. The look, she's a
skinny five years old. She's got the look.
She shaves her head.
She's a beautiful stranger saying,
look is so in writing that 11 Lucas.
So she's 12 she's 12 she's 11.0 she's,
yeah.
And she's like a genuinely good person.
Like when she was talking after the fight,
she's like,
just chomp didn't just be
nice to each other. Here's
the thing, Jill, that's real.
Coming from her. The fans gravitate
towards that nice person. Oh yeah, sure.
When do you look like her? And you
weigh 115 pounds. You're a woman.
You fuck up boogie woman. Yeah. But
you wouldn't maybe. Yeah, I hope so.
Yeah, man. If, if she doesn't become as
big as stars, any other woman in MMA,
I would be stunned. Damn. That would be,
I liked that position because she's a
good person, man. She's worked hard.
Misha Tate got some star out of it.
Rhonda clearly got the biggest right
for sure. Rhonda got the biggest by far.
She was the biggest, like it
was timing her opponents. Yeah.
Everybody's heard and domination or sure.
Opponents just worn on our
level until they were right.
So until she fought Holly,
they weren't really on our level.
And she also had this new thing,
which was the female ass kicker,
this thing that didn't exist before.
So in that way,
like one of the most unique athletes
ever did for sure besides Ali and,
uh, who's the coal miner's
daughter? Christy Martin.
Remember Christy Martin from back in the
old Tyson fights fight on the undercard,
the coal miner's daughter. Remember
that? I'm sure. But the pioneers,
but it's different. Yeah. Not that much.
Like Laila Ali got few
people paying attention.
You better be able to bus your dad's
Mohammad Ali Frat guy. Fuck that man.
That's a shoe in. Yeah, man. But
being George Lucas, his daughter,
like you're going to be, you know in Star
Wars refluxing yeah, but it just never,
it never hit the levels that
it hit with Rhonda. Right.
But I think that it's possible that rose
could be the biggest star in MMA today.
I've really think so.
I don't think anyone's ever going
to be a Rhonda because that was a,
the first one. You know, it
was crazy. Yeah, I agree.
But rose could be gigantic.
I mean, I really think she,
I mean who knows if she could be as big
as Rhonda, but she could be gigantic.
I really think so. Yeah. I liked
that. She's true to herself.
She's fucking nobody out to do.
She does wild shit.
She throws up close second arm bars.
I mean she, she does wild shit.
That fucking karate hottie fight, which
he had kicked her and choked her out.
Dude, she's a little savage. She
keeps on your back. Ooh. That,
that division is kind of stacked though.
Like you want to do a lot of people.
But for rose, there's a lot of
tough competition is very tough.
Competition is tough
competition standing up too.
There's a lot of good strikers in that
division. That's case scenario though.
Especially for the EOC N rose,
cause I'm, you know rose,
my favorite fighter in that
division come from Denver.
But you know that that division for her
to defend it and build a star like the
head and Yolanda, that's when you get a
star. But if that belts circulating, it's,
we can't, the public doesn't gravitate
towards that. We don't like that.
And you know she's likely going to have
to fight Karolina who went five hard
rounds with you,
Ana and three rounds with her.
Was it three or five rounds with her?
What? She wanted a decision three, right?
I think it was three.
There's just a Andraj Jess gone drive.
She's a model like Dasia what? Jessica
and draws beat the shit out of car.
You get a yeah, she beat the brakes off
out of her. That was the man handling.
Nope. Nope. No offense will man handling.
She will manhandled her.
She strong strong arms.
She's slightly rushed. She
smashed the hulk, smashed.
She straight up. Hulk smash.
She's straight up, straight up.
I was like, Jesus Christ, man.
I've seen the ass whooping like that's
in cyber. Got Ahold of some bitch.
Okay.